[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
今日はさまざまなテクノロジーについての話がありました
おそらくこれは私たちの日常生活だけではなくビジネスの面にも大きな影響を与えて
いることと思います
もしかしたら皆さんが働いている環境においてもデジタル化を進めたり
例えばプログラマー
を浅いをしたり色々な変化というのがあると思います
でそのような変化の中で人間はどのような役割があるのでしょうか
これまで ai の時代においてわれわれの仕事がなくなっていくというな危険視をし
た話もあります
じゃあここで私たちが人間として
どのような役割があるのでしょうか
今日はビジネスと人類学というあまり一見関係のないように聞こえるようなコンセプト
ではありますがちょっとお話ししていきたいとおもいます
まずなぜ私が
人類学というような学問に興味を持ったのかというところから
個人的な体験も含めて特に文化と人類学とビジネスということについてお話ししたいと
思いますこれは私が両親と
日本でおそらくも平成の時代だと思います
すごくちょっと地雷感が出ているあの写真なんですがこれは私ですねあの小さいのか
あのこれは私の両親は中国から留学生として日本に
あの
行ってきました私は6歳の時に中国から日本に来ました
当時地元のまあ名古屋なんですが
小学校に公立の小学校に入りました
もちろん私は中国しかわからなかったので
日本語を全くできない方ですもちろん日本の文化についてもわかりません
最初授業があったときはキョロキョロしてました
全く何が起こっているのかわかりませんでしたその時私が何をしたかというと
なんでこの人たちはこういう行動しているんだろう
まずはちょっと理解してみようじゃないかと
あと真似をしてみるそういうことをしていました
私は中学校の時中国に渡りました
これはの高校のときの写真です笑顔の写真をまたを選んだんですが
あのいろんな困難なこともありました私は中国人でありながら中国語ができなくなって
いたんですね日本の文化はわかるけど
中国の文化なかなか分からないそんなようなことがありました
なので最初の頃ももちろん周りの人が何をしているのか
中国のクラスメイトがなんてこういう行動するんだろう
わかんないことがよくあったんですね一つ私が今でも覚えていることがあります
日本では両親に対してありがとう友達に対してありがとう
これは当たり前のことですよねよく言います
え私も中国でそのようなことをしてたんですねで当時は祖母と一緒に住んでました
で祖母にもありが途中号コーデシェと言います
シェイ種とよく言っていましたまあ感謝を表すので当たり前ですよねしかし祖母いった
んです中国では肉親だからこそ
親しい仲だからこそ
わざわざをありがとうって言わないんだよ
その時に何を感じたかというと私がこれまで日本で培った体験
文化的なことが当たり前と思っていたことが中国ではそうでもない
そういうことに気づいたんですね
これで私はあのその後大学に進んで修士課程というまあ大学院に進んで最終的に博士
勝てるというところに行きました
私は香港で博士がをしていたんですがそのときに日本企業
海外における日本企業の文化について勉強したいと思いました
で
それで私は何か何をしたかと言いますとその香港にあるとある日系の氷業に1年半
店員として一緒に働きました
んなのであの笑顔ですねこれはあの離れるときは写真なんですが
なのであの1年半現地の人と一緒に働いたことで何がわかったかというとやはりこれも
また私が当たり前だろうこういう仮説
何何はこうだろうというような仮説を立てていました
しかしこの1年半の経験によって
いや私が思ってる当たり前ということがそうでもない
そういうことに気がつきましたつまりここで何を言いたいかと申し上げますと他社の
理解つまり私たちから見て何
デコイ行動するんだろうよくわからないこういう方々を他者といいんですが
田代の理解する私が小学校にの時にしたこと
高校生の時にしたことそしてその後博士がての時にしたこと
他者への理解これを心がけました
理解というのは受け入れるとは限らないと思っています
でもその理解する姿勢それが重要だと思います
でもう1つ重要なのは当たり前を問い直すということです
やはり一つの文化で長くいますとそれが当たり前だと思ってしまうんですね
それを問い直すこういう作業が実際重要だと思います
チン類学って何なんだろうと有効でまたの本題に戻りたいと思うんですがその先ほど
話した他者を理解する
当たり前を問い直すこれはおそらく全ての人類学者が持っているようなスキルだと思い
ます
源氏での調査をするときにそのような心構えが必要です
この写真はあの中国のと r ところで撮った写真なんですが人類学というとみなさん
おそらく自分からはちょっと遠いというような額も
というふうにお考えになる方が多いかもしれません
例えばどこかの島であったりどこかの村であったりすごく民族的なもの
監修であったり一生であったりそういうものじゃないか
現代のビジネスとどう関係があるんだと思われる方もいるかも知れませんではですね
今どういうふうにビジネスの場面で人類学的な
思考法ですね先ほどしちゃったその二つの手が活用されているのかについてまず動画を
お見せしたいと思います
これ私が撮った動画ではなくてですね youtube にアップされてる動画なん
ですが何をどのような場面かと申しますとゼロックスというアメリカの会社がありまし
た分皆さんもあのコピーキーを
ゼロックスのコピー機使ったことあるかと思うんですがこれは結構ちょっとあの画質
からもお分かりのように少し前のが
像ですでどのような場面かと申し上げますと2人のゼロックスのコンピューターサイン
ですと
のお二人がいるんですが
両面コピーをしようとしますでマニュアルを見たり
それであのシック試行錯誤をするですねあの動画になります a 8 a 5の
サブタイトルはあるんですがちょっと日本語はないんですがあのだいたいそのような
内容ということで
あのご覧頂ければと思いますん
voice and catch a 4用紙の祖母今なら半額
2歳アーム&アップのランチ
うぇ走力自分ですっ
voodoo
me
スタッフブログ
プラスしています
me
ああああああ
goo
じゃ分裂がもが変わってみる従来皆さんプロセッサンってくるという政府と米武器がい
ました
猛暑ぶっぱ
そして雑草がお
おうよさんがうん
えっと最後はですねあの互換ちょっとあの子訳すのが難しいんですが今日はラックが
ないねという話で
あの両面コピーをするのにもすごく死後サーク後していることが分かります後トレイが
どこのトレーナーのかと
ボタン押しても全く反応がないんじゃないかというようなことがおわかりになったかと
思うんですけど
この動画で何を申し上げ
たいかと申しますと
あの技術者が何か製品を作っているときに彼らの視線からそのプロダクト一番良い
プロダクトは何かを考えていることが多いんですね
しかしそれは本当にユーザーにとって一番使いやすいものであるのか
デザインはどうなのかといったところで現在多くの子
西日本でもそうなんですが製品開発
あとはイノベーション製品のイノベーションと言ったところで人類学的なし候補つまり
ユーザーの視点に立って考えて見事そういうようなことをしたわけですね
実際諸説あるんですがこの後にあのゼロックスであの緑色の
あのスタートボタンあるかと思うんですがそこにつながったということが言われてい
ます
後々ゼロックスは8世界においてもあの最初の段階にで人類学者を雇ったというような
ことでも知られていますでは次にですね
で製品開発に限らず例えば人材育成とかそういう
ところで人住民学的思考法って何か活用できないのかそこについて今日はあの台ラック
という事ですので
あのそのようの可能性がないのかどうかについてお話ししたいと思います
この画像を見ていただけると多分1月付くのが多様性ですね色んな人がいる
これが一つだと思いますもう一つ目は皆さん笑っているですね笑顔ということが言える
と思いますしかしよく見ると全く同じ笑顔ってないんですねそれはな
いうかというとやはり一人一人自分が考える映画を英語に対する解釈
違うからですこれは文化的にも違いがあります
例えば日本の小売業では笑顔で接客をする
それは当たり前のことですよねもちろんさはありますしかしそれが当たり前のことに
あっ
ていますしかし私が研究したほっ今ではある
それが当たり前とは限りませんでした
例えば小売業で私が研究していたような量販店では
笑顔で接客するということは当たり前ではありませんでした
なので香港で派遣された日本の管理職の方々が何をしたかったかというとなんで香港人
は笑わないんだと物理的にはられないわけじゃないですよもちろんあの友達と話してる
時は笑うんです
しかしお客さんが来た瞬間にまた顔が変わるという
じゃあこれどうしたらいいんだとそういう
どんな課題を抱えていましたね
しかし私が何を提案したい方を申し上げますと
笑顔笑わせるというよりかは本当にその現地の量販店で笑顔作るということが現地の
顧客にとって一番いいことなのかというところです例えば日本ではおそらくそれが
当たり前なのでそれをするのが一番良いということはできます
しかし評価の基準ですねつまり日本の体験で作られた評価の基準というのは本当に香港
の従業員にとってモチベーションとなるのか
そして本当に現地の顧客にとって一番良いサービスなのでしょうか
例えば香港の顧客の
中には特に量販店であの買い物をする人はスピードを早くしてほしいと
そして知識商品に対する知識
笑顔や丁寧さよりも早く正確に何かをしてほしいというような要望もありますそういう
ような
現地の文化現地の慣習というのをありある程度やはり盛り込む必要があると思うんです
ねしかしこの時に多分企業の方は言いますしかしそんな全部全部件
市穴太に適応しているとなかなか標準化ができないとやはり企業が大きくなっていく上
で標準化は避けて通れません
しかし何をベースに標準化にするのかそれは本当に標準化なのか
そういうような疑問自分が持っている当たり前と考えていることそう
れを見直すことが必要だと思います特に
マネージャーの方々
あの子評価へ考えるような方々にとって必要です
これは経理年例えばですけどゲイ理念を変えるというわけではなくたとえばサービスに
対する理念があるのであればそれを達成するツールを変えるということです
五年自体を変えるということではないというふうに私は館
ん
最後になりましたが私が今日申し上げたいことは実際とてもシンプルです
あの今日いろいろな話の中で技術に関してとかいろいろハードな好き
お話があったんですが私はソフトなスキルも今の ai の時代だからこそ必要だと
思います
特にマインドセット自分が当たり前
自分の物差しでやはり
人間というのは他人をジャッジしてしまうというような行為があります
ビジネスの面においてそれはあの新たな思考や新たな考えというのを
の障害になっているというふうに私は思います
なので私が申し上げることとてもシンプルで簡単なことです
まずは意識してこれまで自分が理解しようとしなかった例えばクライアントであったり
潜在的な顧客であったりもしくは自分の労働環境にいる例えば自分の部下であった
上司であった両親であったりいろんな他社の理解し自分たちが考えているこういうこと
がもしかした思い込みなのではないかというようなところ疑問視して欲しいと思います
以上です本日はありがとうございました
[拍手]